et puis davantage de catégories de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires
devraient pouvoir bénéficier d'un
traitement simplifié de leurs dossiers
au québec assouplissement qui entrera en
vigueur le 24 mai pour les postes
intermédiaires 65 professions sont ici
visés jusqu'ici le traitement simplifié
des dossiers étaient réservées aux
professions spécialisés avec nous ce
soir jean boulet le ministre du travail
du travail de l'emploi de la solidarité
de l'immigration de la francisation et
de l'intégration jeu toujours
impressionné par la longueur de votre
site monsieur goulet bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillion au double le nombre de
professions admissibles au traitement au
traitement simplifié on en ajoute 65 y
en avait déjà 220 et donc ses 65 là vont
pouvoir vérifier comme vous dites du
traitement simplifié donc des permis de
travail qui vont pouvoir durer trois ans
au lieu d'une année une simplification
au niveau du processus il y aura plus de
limites quant au nombre de travailleurs
étrangers temporaires qu'un
établissement ou en employant pour en
faire venir combien avons-nous accueilli
de travailleurs étrangers temporaires
par exemple en 2021 à peu près 25 mai
lan en tenant compte des travailleuses
agricoles et l'on entre ses parents
recevoir encore plus le dépendamment des
besoins surtout un contexte de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre plusieurs milliers des
travailleurs étrangers temporaires et
clé pour l'autre programme qui réfère à
la mobilité internationale soso sera
7000 par année mais santé des
travailleurs qualifiés qui ont déjà un
certificat de sélection du québec qui
sont à l'étranger et qui vont pouvoir
venir dans le contexte d'un autre
opération main d'oeuvre donc ça peut
être des ingénieurs des enseignants des
éducateurs éducatrices des infirmiers
infirmières donc ça devrait être
bénéfique pour nos employeurs vous dites
65 profession un supplémentaire
opérateurs de machines d'usinage
manutentionnaire bouche et industriel
c'est les aimants éléments mentionnés
par manufacturiers et exportateurs du
québec qui salue votre votre annonce
aujourd'hui la fédération canadienne de
l'entreprise indépendante dit toutefois
vous allez pas assez loin vous n'allez
pas assez vite on devrait élargir
complètement ouvrir davantage on est à
plus de deux cent mille postes vacants
au québec oui absolument à écouter quand
même faut reconnaître que c'est une
bouffée d'air frais et ça fait référence
à beaucoup de type d'occupation qui
requièrent moins de qualification il ya
les conducteurs de camions l'épreuve les
préposés aux bénéficiaires ya les aides
enseignants aux niveaux primaire et
secondaire débouchés industriels quand
on pense à la transformation alimentaire
il ya les opérateurs de machines
d'usinage comme vous mentionnez donc
quand même près de 300 métiers
profession sur l'iss un sens qui font
partie de la classification nationale
des professions ont fait un immense pas
en avant mais quand on entre 200000
postes vacants ou à peu près on tourne
autour de 200 mille postes de calais
vous parler de quelques milliers de
personnes de plus on répond on vient pas
de tout régler à court et à court et à
moyen terme moyen terme pardon le
problème corner de pilules mineurs
écoutez la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre sa
rapière l'addition de plusieurs
solutions si on revient au 30 novembre
dernier quand j'annonçais que le premier
ministre qui ma collègue un enseignement
supérieur la vaste offensive pour la
main d'oeuvre souvenez vous on a les
bourses perspective que c'est des
montants de quins en donnant à par
session complète aux collégiens 2500 $
par session complétée au niveau
universitaire et ça c'est dans des
secteurs névralgiques des technologies
de l'information le génie la
construction la santé l'éducation
donc il ya beaucoup de gars 80 mesures à
ces trois points 9 milliards de dollars
dont 2.9 milliards de nouveaux crédits
on a parlé du salaire minimum le salaire
minimum va monter dans un mois 14
dollars 25 l'heure vous avez évoqué que
le salaire minimum
minimum monte à 15 dollars en 2023
est-ce que c'est certain son nom jeu
c'est une question qui m'a été posée et
j'anticipe évidemment avec le contexte
inflationniste avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui exercent une pression forte
sur les salaires dans les entreprises
que nous puissions aller jusqu'à 15
dollars l'année prochaine parce que vous
savez qu'on un critère objectif là c'est
que le salaire minimum soit équivalent
50 % du salaire horaire moyen
toujours dans un contexte si on veut
trouver un équilibre entre
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
salariés à faible revenu et le métier de
la compétitivité des pme on s'entend que
le pouvoir d'achat il disparaît pas mais
à la vinification moment est-ce qu'une
15 dollars s'est vraiment passé ben je
pense que le
50% du salaire horaire moyen c'est quand
même un critère objectif
et pourquoi pas seulement ce critère-là
en europe on est à 60% du salaire médian
le mfr qu'on appelle la mfr 60 pourquoi
pourquoi vous basez-vous absolument sûrs
de 50% je pense qu'il faut y aller
progressivement
et c'est ce que nous faisons c'est la
première fois depuis notre arrivée au
pouvoir qu'on atteint 7,6 blood 50% du
salaire horaire moyen il ya plusieurs
économistes avec lesquels j'ai travaillé
qui me confirme la légitimité de cette
cible là parce que ça respecte
l'évolution d'économie en tenant compte
de l'accroissement de la productivité
c'est une cible évidemment puis faut pas
négliger le fait que de penser à 14 et
25 de 13 et 50 à 14,25 ces cinq points 6
% d'augmentation 300 à 1000 travailleurs
travailleuses on en bénéficie et là
dedans et un pourcentage
58 59 pour cinq sont des jeunes de 15 à
24 ans faut faire attention aux pme qui
ont été fragilisés par la pandémie
plusieurs sont endettés ya plus de
dangers de trot monté puis de sortir les
jeunes des écoles c'est un élément le
décrochage scolaire peut être un des
facteurs que nous considérons dans la
détermination du salaire minimum mais
dans ce qui détermine puis dans du côté
syndical par exemple on dit 18 $ parce
qu'on veut amener les gens à un revenu
minimum viable plus que passer le seuil
de pauvreté là arrive et puis bien bien
vivre en travaillant 35 heures par
semaine vous avez totalement raison puis
la chaire de recherche en fiscalité et
finances publiques de l'université de
sherbrooke confirme que dans plusieurs
catégories notamment familles
monoparentales ou en couple avec deux
enfants en termes de revenus disponibles
on est les premiers au canada avec les
présomptions relativement bien parce
qu'on a un filet social au québec et
particulièrement généreux faut tenir
compte de cette donnée merci monsieur
voulait d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci monsieur fillion pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit